if
if you
Well, good morning church. My name is Phil Sally and I'm the
new pastor on staff. And so this is kind of
like a blind date. You don't know me and I don't know
you and we're trying to figure this out and we're gonna hope it goes. Well,
my daughter came to the service.
And so if you don't like this, this is her fault.
She's the one that sent me the link about this job posting. And anyway,
Scott that was like the dating app.
If you will. The reason that I'm here is that
Alan Rice one of
our elders was slated to speak today and I was going to speak next week.
And then yesterday I was playing pickleball until about 10 AM and
then I go to my car and I have about a dozen messages
and I'm new so I don't get messages right
now. And the first one said brother John
and brother field. I'm not feeling really good can
feel trade with me.
and I'm like
I've got a date tomorrow anyway, so if
you let's not make this awkward, we're
gonna do it and I've done some preaching before so I want
to introduce myself. I'm the pastor of discipleship and
community and I can't think of a more
exciting calling than to be the pastor discipleship and
Community to a church who's vision statement says that
we want to become a hub for an
all ages disciple making movement. I
can't believe that God picked me
to be here and I want to thank Pastor John
and our Elder counselor for letting me preach. I
believe this is a sacred honor preaching is a high responsibility
and a privilege and so I'm excited
about doing this and so we've been locked looking at
Parables and Parables of stories that Jesus told and
they were stories that told about the kingdom of God and
how the kingdom of God is different from the kingdom of the
world. And so you're gonna see worldly values and Kingdom values
and Jesus often would take
And we'll see today how he would take a story
and then he would compare and contrast worldly values
from Kingdom values. But beyond that today,
we're not going to just see this difference, but we're going to
hear Jesus tell a story a very famous story about
the infinite love of God and the extraordinary expectations
that God had for his people. So
you have your Bibles turn to Luke 10 and while you're
turning there, this is a crowd participation moment. I'm going to ask you
a question and you're gonna need to be able to raise your
hand. I want you to keep it up. And as
long as you can until we get
to the end here how many of you ever lived in a house
in a neighborhood raise your hand keep it up how many
of you've lived in an apartment or a dormitory or
you've been camping and you've shared Campground
space now in a few
seconds, I'm gonna ask you to drop your hand if you've ever had neighborhood
problems ever had a problem neighbor
one of you
No, no, we're not done and keep those
hands up. You are definitely tell there's a Baptist crowd. I say put
your hands up.
So one of your neighbors is overstepped
or underperformed or showed poor Behavior or
the music was too loud or the grass was too long. It had uncontrolled pets or
uninhibited actions are offended by you on the count of
three. If you've ever had neighbor problems, then you
can drop your hands one, two three.
Okay, just a couple didn't drop their
hands.
If you've never had neighbor problems, is it possible that you were
the problem neighbor?
I'm sorry, I don't know you but we'll get to know each other
better later. Anyway, that that
joke works every time by the way, let's talk
a little bit about neighbors. One of my favorite experts on neighbors Fred
Rogers. And if you don't know who Mr. Rogers is then you're
too young. And so maybe you've seen Tom Hanks
play Fred Rogers, but he had a show called Mr. Rogers neighborhood
and he started every show with the same song and
it will something like this by the way, John asked
me to where cardigan sweater
and changing my shoes and
He's gone, so I don't have to do that. Anyway, just
kidding. Oh, this is
not the one that goes out on live stream. But anyway,
This is the song. It says it's a beautiful
day in the neighborhood a beautiful day. But neighbor the last
three questions. Would you be mine? Could you
be mine and all together? We sing won't you be
my neighbor. It's like praise and worship in here,
wasn't it?
Well, that's not as easy
as it sounds it's a good song, but did you
see how many hands went down?
I mean Jesus told this story a parable
to explain these Kingdom expectations and in
Luke 10:25, a
lawyer asks a question. Now this lawyer is not
like we understand the word lawyer. This is an expert in the Old Testament
law and it's his job to interpret the law.
And so there's this problem and there are several problems in
his questioning of Jesus and we read about it in verse 25
and behold a lawyer stood up to put him
to the test.
Saying teacher what shall I do to inherit eternal
life and he said to him? No, Jesus Jesus
asking the lawyer.
What is written in the law?
And how do you read it?
So we see this lawyer stand up and we know
that this is a Pharisee scribe. He's a Pharisee because the Sadducees
are the Jewish aristocracy. They don't believe in the eternal
life. And so this is a Pharisee whose job
is to interpret the written Old Testament law and
the talmud or the oral Traditions. He's an
expert. Okay, and he stands up which means he's probably
at an official teaching of Jesus.
Where you sit at the feet of the teaching rabbi?
What an amazing opportunity to sit at
the feet of the master teacher Jesus and to hear him teach,
but the lawyer doesn't see it like that.
The lawyer put him to the test. Now the
Greek term test implies evil motives. When
used elsewhere in the New Testament. It
means leaning towards destruction. So this lawyer has
an aggressive confrontation planned of
Jesus. He's not interested in asking Jesus about
his own spiritual need he's not interested in having
Jesus answer questions that he has in order to become a
better person or more Godly. He's trying to
trap Jesus to discredit Jesus to harm
his
Is just to hurt him.
Right. And so that's number one
point and by the way, if because this
was quick we didn't get the paper notes, but
if you would like to turn in your app to the notes and there's
notes for the you to follow along and so just once you
know, if you know what that means and go ahead and if you don't I'm sorry, there's nothing
and we can do.
So Point number one, is this Jesus?
Is not to be tested.
In fact, I would say Jesus is to be trusted. Do not
test Jesus. This is a pattern repeated throughout
the New Testament people trying to test Jesus and it never
ends will for people who want to challenge Jesus.
You remember that before Jesus ministry. He
was led by the Holy Spirit Into the Wilderness to
be tempted of the devil the tempter. And so the tempter
asked him to change stones into bread and he says it's written man
will not live by bread alone. But the second question was this he takes
him to the holy city to the Pinnacle of the temple and
he says jump off of here and it is written
and it alarms me that the Bible that the devil knows the Bible, but
he he quotes from scripture and he says that the that God
will give the Angels charge concerning you lest your desk your
foot against a stone.
And this is what Jesus says.
he says
Again, it is written you shall not
put the Lord your God to the test.
So testing Jesus means you don't
know Jesus.
You don't understand what he's done for you the sacrifice that
he's made for you. You're not familiar with how passionate and
Healy he loves you and pursues you see
testing. Jesus means you've never experienced the perfect
Heart of Jesus.
How he loves and how he gives and how he serves and how he reflects
God's glory.
And let me ask let me ask you a favor. Okay? I'm
an old school preacher. Okay. I've been preaching a really long time. And
so your ability to say Amen during
the sermon is in complete correlation to my ability to
to stop on time.
Okay. Amen. She's got some place to be. Yeah, she
liked that one. So I'm about to get
I'm gonna describe Jesus for you just very briefly and if
you can concur with me as to who
this Jesus is, then you could say Amen if
you never have this is your opportunity to give it a try, you know,
see how I feel so, okay, Jesus is
Emmanuel that means god with us. He is
friend Living Water bread of life lighter the
world. He is Miracle Worker Lamb of
God King of Kings Lord of lords. He is the returning
ruler and is God who knows and loves
you. Amen.
You see if you test Jesus it's because
you don't know Jesus and that's a problem. And this
lawyer doesn't know Jesus and he confirms
his ignorance with this question. He exposes the
second problem. And this is the second truth. There's nothing you
can do to inherit eternal life.
What can you do to inhibitory inherit eternal life
nothing?
He says teacher what shall I do to inherit eternal
life? What shall I do that implies personal action? He thinks there's
something he can do. He wants to know. What is it?
See, this is one of the most deeply entrenched human
beliefs that a person must do something to
impress God or to earn his favor. But that
question even contains a contradiction. What does
anyone do to earn an inheritance? Nothing you
just were born in the right family?
Right and inheritance isn't something you earn it
comes as a gift. It's based upon a relationship not
on performance.
So you don't do something to inherit anything?
But this lawyer like most first century
Jews believe that his salvation was based upon his actions
or his ability to obey the Mosaic law, but
listen to me and by the way, if you're new here and
you've not heard this explained you this
is the gospel. This is the good news This Is
Why We Gather and sing praises to Jesus because what if
he's done for us?
Humanity is evil.
We are sinful Romans 3:23 says for
all of sin and fall short of the glory of God.
You see God's laws are written as a reflection of his character.
That's why it is intensely perfect and impossible
to obey perfectly the purpose
of the law then is to expose our sinfulness. We
cannot be saved by our own action,
but listen to the good news.
Romans 6:23 for the wages of sin is
death. That's what we deserve. That's what we've earned. But the
free gift of God is eternal life through Jesus Christ
Our Lord. Amen.
For by grace, are you saved through faith that not
of yourselves. It is a gift of God not of
works so that no one can boast. So Jesus
turns the question back on the lawyer.
He turns the tables and he asks the lawyer. What
does the law say? And how do you read it? You see
Jesus because he's a good Rabbi often asks questions. And
he answers this question with a
question. What is written in the in the law? And how do
you read it? And the lawyer answers correctly. He
says you should love the Lord your God with all your heart with all
your soul with all your strength with all
your mind and your neighbor as yourself.
And Jesus said to him you have answered correctly do
this and you will live that
phrase you have answered correctly. What if Jesus
had stopped there? Well, the expert in the law would have
thought himself nailed it and he would have loved for
everybody. No, you know, he got it right. That's excellent. But that's not what
Jesus did he did not stop and the lawyer desperately
needed to hear the very next phrase you
have answered correctly. And then he said something very
important.
Do this and you will live.
Notice Jesus doesn't say answer correctly and
you will live he says do this and you will
live you see religious people can get this really mixed up.
Sometimes we think it's the spiritual people are the
people who know all about the Bible are able to give the correct answers.
That's what the expert in the law thought.
He did know a lot about the Bible and he did get the correct answer. But this
is what Jesus doesn't said.
Jesus says
you have answered correctly do this.
So Jesus is saying to God the main thing
is to actually do the loving.
The main thing for you and me
is to actually do this to love God with all
that we have as God defines love and and that's
one thing. I love about Henderson Hills Baptist Church.
And one of the reasons that I believe God called me here is I believe
with all my heart and our mission and vision and one
of our and our mission is equipping one another to love
Jesus and to live scent this Parable is
all about living sin. It's on the road again.
And one of our compelling core values is compelling
love which says we demonstrate the
love of Jesus by respecting the Dignity of every person.
Sacrificing for our neighbors and cultivating Unity
for our faith family.
So Jesus says do this.
And you will live.
Now the expert in the law. I can't just walk away. He's hooked.
It's like he knows Jesus knows I
don't really do this.
But he wants to be justified and he
wants to justify himself.
And that's inside all of us, isn't it? I mean, we all want
to be justified. We all want to look good. We all want to
appear dignified or legitimate. We all want
to be right or to be proven, right? We all want to
be regarded as correct or even Superior. So
the lawyer asks a second revealing question.
And who is my neighbor?
Desiring to justify himself
He asks who is my neighbor? This is
another point. It's not on your notes, but you can't
justify yourself. If you try to justify yourself. It's
a problem, but it's a problem for eternity.
The expert in the law is saying to himself. Hey, I'm
an expert in the law. If anybody deserves
to be justified, it's me.
He's looking for a loophole. Okay, so if I have to
love my neighbor then in fact, who is my neighbor?
Who am I obligated to have to love who is
the category that fits neighbor that makes me
obligated to love? In fact who is eligible to
receive my love? You see the lawyer is insinuating that
there were some who were simply not worthy to
be considered his neighbor.
This is his attempt for self justification.
But what he doesn't know is that Jesus is the lawgiver.
He gave us the law. But Jesus is also the law of
fulfiller who came to fulfill the law.
He is the one who would fulfill the requirements of
the law.
Not the lawyer.
He wants to earn what he gets. He wants to use a balance scale. I'm a
good man. Not a bad guy. I'm a good guy, but see
instead of answering the question who is my
neighbor. Jesus tells a story.
It's a very famous story.
And Jesus is not going to answer the question.
Who is my neighbor? Let's look at verse 30.
Now remember in this story you're going to see a stark difference
in between worldly values.
And Kingdom values verse 30 Jesus replied A
man was going down from Jerusalem to Jericho and he fell
among robbers who stripped him and beat him and departed leaving him half
dead.
So what do we know about the man left half dead?
Well, we know he was stripped and beaten we know he was left alone
to die.
Other than that, we have no idea what he was really like
was he a good man or a bad man? Jesus doesn't say was it
an Israelite or a gentile? Jesus doesn't say
See, there's only one potential neighbor in
the story that Jesus tells and Jesus intentionally.
Doesn't say very much about him.
Jesus is not going to answer the question who is
my neighbor instead. Jesus tells a story
of three different people who have the potential to
love their neighbor.
And the first character with a potential to love his neighbors
a Jewish priest.
He is educated in the law. It's the highest Jewish religious
official. This is what Jesus says Now by chance a
priest was going down that road and when he saw him
he passed by on the other side.
Since he was going down, it means that he was traveling away
from Jerusalem. He might have even just visited the
temple in rabbinical law mandates him
as a priest to bury a
corpse, but this man is half dead. See he can recite the
Commandments about neighbors. He could lead the
service the worship religious meeting and
and he he prays he makes sacrifices in
front of people. So he's reminded all the time about
what it means to to show God's
love and to look God's forgiveness and God's mercy you
can expect that love has been formed
in this priest.
Except it. Hasn't
The second character with potential to love their neighbor is a
levite.
Now he's an assistant to the priest. He's educated but
a little less educated and even a little less educated than the
lawyer but the law requires him to show my Mercy
even to strangers and enemies.
Verse 32 so likewise a levite when
he came to the place and saw him.
Passed by on the other side.
He too has heard the official teachings about the
The time that we need God's love
and God's forgiveness and God's mercy and the way we should
show it but you can expect too that love has
been formed inside this Levi.
Except it. Hasn't
See the priest and levite failed someone in need that
was right in front of them.
Love and care are most urgently needed by those
who are right in front of us.
We owe care specifically to the
who have an immediate need right here right now.
Would you be my neighbor? Could you
be my neighbor won't you be my neighbor?
The problem with the priests and the levite is that didn't seem to care.
And they might have had lots of excuses to why but the text doesn't
tell us what those excuses were.
So being Pious and religious sometimes can
get in the way.
the third character with the potential to love
The neighbor was a Samaritan. I'm
going to go on and on about this but let's read verses 33 through
34 but a Samaritan as he journeyed came
to where he was and when he saw him he had compassion.
And he went to him and bound up his wounds and pouring on
oil and wine. He set him on his own animal and
brought him to the inn and took care of him.
Then the next day he took out two dinere and he
gave them to The Innkeeper saying take care of him.
Whatever more you spend I will repay you when I come
back.
I am
this stuns the Jewish
audience. They are in 100% absolute shock
listening to a story about a Samaritan
doing the right thing. They don't know the
law. They don't follow the scriptures. In fact,
they're despised half breeds when it comes to the Jewish Elite.
The Samaritans and the Jews for a long time have been
bitter enemies.
Jews would have to travel through Samaria.
And a lot of times the Samaritans would attack the Jews.
And Jesus tells a story about this man on this road being attacked.
And it was a Samaritan who showed compassion.
Jews considered Samaritans to be human filth
and the Samaritans knowing that would do ungodly and
Unholy things just to make the Jews repulsed
by them.
Yet the Samaritan is the pattern.
We saw the problem now the pattern and the
pattern is someone you wouldn't expect is this Jesus
teaching Us in perfect clarity that anyone can
be loved and anyone can
love others the love of God in Jesus Christ
is for any and everyone. Amen.
This is the third truth good examples are defined by
their acts of compassion and mercy.
Yes compassion and mercy makes you a good
example, but a Samaritan when he saw the man he had
compassion. What does that even mean? It means
that when he sees someone right in front of him beating up stripped and
robbed and left for dead. He must do something.
There might have been certain questions go through his mind. Like what was
it like to be beaten and left like this? What is it like to
be stripped and robbed and left for dead. How awful
would it be if that were me? How even worse would it
be if that were someone that I love what's gonna happen to
this man if I just leave him here?
Could I do something? Could I help him?
Could I change this?
Do I have anything else more important in my life than doing
this?
And this is absolutely vital.
How did the priest and the levite respond to those questions? Well, they
didn't because they didn't even think about them.
They might have had their own questions.
I wonder if the robbers still might be
around am I in danger?
Why didn't the Romans post a guard here for our own safety?
What are my tax dollars for?
Why doesn't somebody do something?
This is the fourth truth worldly thoughts are
self-motivated and self-centered.
They are self-motivated.
and self-centered
worldly thoughts are all about me myself and I
my own agenda my own Ambitions my own expectations and
if the worldly thoughts that run inside
my head are self-motivated and self-centered about
me myself and I my own selfish agenda.
then
It is inevitable that it will be reflected in what I
do.
And what I refuse to do.
So we want to step away from the pattern and look at the potential now
and this is the this is the gotcha. Aha moment
that I hope that the holy spirit will lay on your heart today.
Jesus says in verse 36, which of these do you think prove
to be a neighbor to the man who fell among robbers?
the lawyer said
the one who showed him Mercy
and Jesus said you go and do likewise.
See Mercy In this passage is a costly type
of Love Mercy is a compassion that
is willing to pay the price Mercy is
what a judge might do extend to
a criminal or a king might extend to a subject or mostly for
us today Mercy is what God in Christ
extends to Sinners Like Me.
The question is no longer.
Who is eligible to receive my love? It's not.
That's not the question.
the fifth truth
is what? I hope that you'll take away from me if I said nothing else.
This Is It Love is God's
great opportunity
The question is what kind of person is able to offer love?
The lawyer couldn't even bring himself to say the word Samaritan.
He told Jesus.
The one who gave him Mercy yet. Jesus
said you go and do likewise.
Put yourself motivation yourself expectation
yourself.
All yourself put it behind you and love God
purely and perfectly love others
as you love yourself love others as Christ loves
you go and do and you will live which
brings us to our sixth and final truth.
Jesus says this
the whole shocking story just comes back to
this one three word phrase go.
Do this.
Just to make the point of the story clear and
plain. He says go and do and church. That's our
Command to
Go and do likewise go in love.
Now I've not been here very long about a month.
And and I don't know a hundred percent of the
things there is to know about this church, but I do know this about this church.
Henderson Hills does not want to be the church
that just gives the right answers.
We want to love Jesus and lives scent that
means that we are going and we are loving no
matter the risk at Great sacrifice just
like Jesus and only God can do that through us.
We must every day go to God and ask him
God. Would you remind me just how much you love
me so that I will go and love others.
Remember who spoke this parable?
It was Jesus telling a story about mercy and compassion.
It was Jesus who was just about to head for the cross.
Jesus is the ultimate example of
refusing to pass by on the other side.
He chose instead to show compassion and
mercy at Great personal cost.
So we give and we serve and we
help just like Jesus and when we
do we're taking part in God's greatest opportunity.
Listen to what Paul said in second Corinthians 5:20.
Paul who spent most of his adult life in prison
writing letters so that we could read them and study
therefore
we are ambassadors for Christ.
An ambassador someone who acts as a representative, so we're Christ's
Representatives.
Certain of this that God is making his appeal
through us.
We implore you on Christ's behalf be reconciled
to God for our sake he
made him who did not know sin become sin
for us. So that in him we might become the
righteousness of God. This is God's greatest opportunity.
Every day at the start of each day. We must
ask ourselves how
I display the righteousness of God today.
If you're a disciple of Jesus, this is your potential.
This is God's greatest opportunity.
Jesus himself said a new command I give
you that you love one another just as I have loved
you. You are also to love one another and by
this will all men know that you're my disciples if
you have love for one another.
I got to tell you is the pastor of discipleship and Community. If
we don't become the most loving thing then I've found as
your leader.
We have got to seize this potential
and God's greatest opportunity.
Look at First John 3.
Now as I say this, I went I want you to remember that Jesus
on the cross refused to pass by.
He saw someone in real need and that was you and
that was me and he showed compassion and
mercy see Jesus Crown was a crown of thorns and
his robe was bloodstained. And this is
what John said about him by this we know love.
That he laid down his life for us and we ought
to lay down our lives for the brothers.
But if anyone has the world's goods
and sees a brother in need yet closes his heart against
him.
How does God's love abide in him?
Little children, let us not just love in word
or talk but in deed and in
truth.
George we all have neighbors
And we all have neighbors with the potential to love. We
all have neighbors that live in our neighborhood and
we have to ask.
Would you be mine?
Could you be mine won't you be my neighbor? How will
I display the righteousness of God today?
And you can be creative in this and this isn't
just the easy stuff like helping them with their lawn or helping
with their trash or waving them when they're nice. You know what we
have. You know, I'm just gonna I don't know. Yeah, I don't know where you
live. I haven't seen your car, but just about every car's got windows that
are tinted now.
So you can get in that car. You can drive home.
You don't have to look at anybody. You don't have to wave to
anybody you don't have to smile anybody and you
get on me hit a little button your garage door goes up. You can drive right
in you hit the garage doors like
Didn't have to talk to any neighbors today is a good day. That's
what we do. That's who we are.
How can I display the righteousness?
of God today
Hey, it's 100 degrees roll down your window.
warm smile a sincere greeting a
friendly conversation start a friendship, but that's not what the
that's not what the Samaritan did.
He picked up this broken man, and he put him
on his own.
Horse or whatever you had and he took him
and he paid and it was costly. What does our
neighbor need to show God's love and display his
righteousness today.
We have neighbors.
At school. I hate to tell you students this but
about a month you're going back.
But is God big enough to put you
in school near a first hour neighbor that
needs love from you is God
big enough to put you in a second hour neighbor is God big enough
to put you in a neighborhood of a team or of
a club or of a man. You better believe God's
got a plan and that a plans you that that
plan includes you and that is God's greatest opportunity
for you to be the Samaritan in that person's life.
We have neighbors here right here at church.
I'm new. I just met a
couple back here that they've been here about it eight months. They're there the
old folks in this relationship, right? And so I will
walk through the hallways and I'll just like
I don't know anybody.
But I'm gonna fake it till I make it y'all be like,
hey good. See you. Hey friend. Hey brother, you know and I
need your help to say. Hey my name so and so and then
let's get together and have some lunch have some coffee and a lot of people are
doing that because
We have neighbors right here in church.
And what do they need from you? Well, they need a sacrificial gift
not just your money but your time and
your effort and your gentleness a gentle response and
offer to help.
A text a phone call a handwritten note, maybe an
invitation to sit with you or to go to lunch after church or maybe
come along with you to a community group. So I don't really like that
group. Well, I'll go with you to another group until you find one.
So that you're asking a little much.
Faster. I'm going to say well.
I'm not gonna say what I'm gonna say. Okay too new to be making
enemies right now. All right.
You just never know think about this. You just
never know when a neighborhood moment's going to break through.
When Love happens just like Jesus loves you
you have an opportunity to give and to serve and to help like
Jesus. I want to finish up with a story
that that struck me this week. Okay.
When we moved here, some of you may know this. My mom
is 87. She has dementia. She broke her hip and
so we had to put her in an assisted living Memory Care
Facility because she doesn't need full-time care, but she's
there with a bunch of ladies who also have memory problems
and they don't know one another but they sit together
for breakfast lunch and dinner every day.
And so I've made a commitment to go see my mom every day and
sometimes as I just see her but sometimes I go at lunch
time and I have decided because this
is be honest, the priest and
levite in me is not that excited about going to the memory
care place.
You know, they're not gonna remember it.
And I'm justifying myself. If you won't even know I
can tell her I was there and she'll believe me. You know, I mean,
I can do all of those things right and inside of me I
justify myself and I've never done that but I've wanted to
But instead I go and I look around and a lot of these ladies don't
have family that comes to see them every day. And so when I sit down
at lunch with them and it makes me emotional to say this because this
is God's greatest opportunity.
I work at remembering their names.
Surely my mom sits right here next to
her is Diane and then there's Rita and there's Barbara
and there's Lila and there's Marianne and for
some reason they put Jean the dude right there, too.
And they all want me to eat. I don't eat
because it costs money to eat there. And so I don't eat but
there are like you want some
Not that hungry nothing at every meal. No, thanks. I
just my mom says well, why are
you here?
And I said, I'm just here to entertain the table. Okay, and so
I start, you know, I start doing the thing.
It's the preacher thing. I've been doing it a long time, right? Hey,
how's it going Rita? She says it looks at
me like who you know and you know me, but I work at
one time at least one time per meal
to make everybody at the table smile.
And you know why it's not their gift. It's
my gift.
And now for some reason I don't regret having to
go see my mom because God has given me a purpose there
and that's the purpose.
To be the righteousness of God to a group of little
ladies. It'll never know it.
And he's got that same opportunity for every one of
us.